[Music]
meet soda pop you shouldn't be able to
do this on Twitch it's not talking about
like that this is my passion the only
guy on twitch who gets to stream
whatever he wants and tens of thousands
of people will show up to watch now
attend easy baby we're up 2.5 k he's
everything and nothing you'd expect
skinny and blonde witty and topical a
gamer but one who doesn't really care
what game he's playing
maybe the hex this is the game flute I
recommend it he really want me to put
he's flanked on screen by dozens of
viewer donated gifts the [ __ ] am I gonna
do with this thing
tokens of appreciation symbols of the
participatory experience he offers as
much as I hate the meme this is pretty
cool he's riffing on the latest internet
meme getting in trouble in gta5 and
leveling in Wow nice
tell me grad sir you're [ __ ] racist
he's fever riot ii streamer look at this
quality the graphics our next-generation
showing you the life you've always
dreamed of living one without rules
limits borders or bedtimes
he's soda pop twitches OG if you want to
get to know chance soda pop and Morris
we're gonna have to transport you back
to a time when twitch didn't exist
nobody had an Instagram account and
blackberries were cooler than high rose
that year was 2008 and was also when
sodapoppin started his career on a now
extinct live streaming platform called
Xfire so like let's just live stream on
Xfire so I live streamed on there it's
like boom I was pretty good at where to
work up at the time so I got lot of
viewers cuz that and no one else streams
so they had no one else to watch Plus
sounds like dealing with the webcams
like they had to come to me right that
experience on Xfire proved to be
invaluable as a hood soda in a unique
position when twitch launched since he
had already spent the past four years in
front of a webcam and then twitch kind
of blew up
and even with my potato PC I was getting
a lot of viewers you know I was already
established cuz I started so early it
was easy to get in because of that and
even then in twitches early years when
it was widely seen as a place for
gameplay footage it was evident that
sodapoppin had a flair for the
outlandish that just did a bunch of dumb
[ __ ] on cameras right in sharpie on my
face I danced for donations I was just a
complete sellout before the just
chatting or IRL sections even existed
his twitch stream served as a window
into his day-to-day life yes you can can
I have an ultimate chicken grill and it
was there ranting about games
live-streaming everything he could and
acting goofy online that some of his
most loyal viewers on the Internet fell
in love with him eat [ __ ] sherry you've
never got adoration like that he gave me
five thousand more dollars what the [ __ ]
during that early Wow era from 2012 to
2014 his constant memeing and talk show
personality paired well with his
impressive gameplay so you Sonny Stein
stop he's dead he's dead
that's [ __ ] dead
ass mad after all in 2014 sodapoppin
reached
ranked number one in Wow PvP but that
didn't stop him from walking his viewers
through his every decision thought it
made a game so well that art bat opener
we had was just so brutal for them
there's no aching back on that as twitch
started to grow into the streaming
behemoth it is today soda was one of its
most prominent figures and was
attracting as many as 30,000 followers a
month in fact there were days when more
than half of twitches total world of
warcraft audience were watching him he
will melt eventually keep it up don't
him get away there's no way he can take
out one of us easily but all of us if we
keep spam rising there's no [ __ ] way
of course a lot of that can be
attributed to the personality first
content he was creating in an era where
that kind of channel was hard to come by
his viewers stayed followed and
subscribed to him and that kind of
loyalty is something we've now come to
understand as irreplaceable on Twitch I
do I'm gonna have you know a guild
everyone can join but if your subscriber
I'm gonna promote you obviously in the
guild to some sort of rank where you're
gonna have a lot more power than the
other guys trends can come and go online
but having that same core group on his
channel every day is the absolute dream
of twitch streamers hello gents I think
I'm your biggest fan I've been watching
your stream for over one year I'm I am
making this video now because I've been
trying to get in touch with you and so
too paid back that loyalty in
versatility what is the first game I
want everyone to guess and no it's not
League of Legends does anyone know what
the first game is whether you're getting
that Dark Souls can I get a bra for Dark
Souls there's a serious risk that comes
with variety streaming massive
followership is often tied to specific
games on Twitch and by trying new games
and trying to conquer the Uncharted
water of variety games soda risked
losing money but he refused to do
anything just for viewership he'd only
play what he and his chat wanted and it
paid off the only one you're allowed to
play out of all Leisure Suit Larry
Grand Theft Auto time ah here comes here
comes here goes [ __ ] he never let wow be
his anchor and that decision ended up
defining his career in 2015 sodapoppin
cemented himself as much more than a
World of Warcraft streamer I quit world
of warcraft that's huge
confirmed acquit wow that game sucks
nowadays the PvP is stale I'm bored I
don't like it if it ever gets good again
I'll go back to and after quitting Wow
for a while in 2015 so to set the mold
for what playing and doing absolutely
anything and everything on twitch looks
like he played everything from the
hottest battle royale in h1z1 to the
latest Grand Theft Auto title to
streaming footage of his dog making new
friends and here comes the [ __ ] fruit
Hut
and that variation also saw him get into
gambling okay we're gonna stand we're
gonna hope that this guy either gets 17
or busts stand we won whoa we won 25
bucks that year online casinos and skin
betting became a fixture of his stream
yes
[Music]
yes 20 okay actually okay
stand stand [ __ ] [ __ ] joy
Twitter face card just don't get 21 no
way sodas always being a polarizing
figure who has never been afraid to
speak his mind
so in this perfect storm of content
creation meets life advice meets
performance art we had a 21 year old
going all-in on the internet both
literally and figuratively all right
[ __ ] it I'm all-in Andy
[Music]
soda even took some heat during that era
when he was betting exposing his young
fans to gambling so blatantly was
certainly on brand but also
irresponsible with such a large
following now attend easy boom baby
we're at 2.5 k during august of 2015
sodapoppin averaged more than 21,000
viewers at a time and followed that up
with more than 22,000 on average in
september he was growing rapidly and he
was doing it by broadcasting whatever
the hell he wanted hello
okay I'm sorry I didn't know I was
supposed to run can you take a picture
with me I'm the guy at the black hoodie
behind your [ __ ] 80 out I'll get you
later man I'm not taking pictures while
I'm streaming man but soda shattered the
barriers between himself and his chatted
to him they were more than viewers they
sent him gifts decided on the streams
music and sometimes even dictated the
games he play alright high chance enjoy
your gift also can I please have mod
John Cena would approve of me having
mine from springy HD okay so it's from
spring eh
Wow
the 90 90 seconds is yours and this is
what you choose to do with it
it was like he brought his channel a
real subscription service something
tangible and participatory that was more
than just spectating the wheel landed on
the stream gets to decide what I buy on
Amazon for myself an epically happy Bob
Ross parody poster with happy little
trees and that is it this is what you
all picked out in 2016
soda used the money he made and the
success of his stream to jump into
eSports where he became a co-owner of
northern gaming I am handling the world
of warcraft side of things and northern
gaming I personally went out and hand
selected a lot of teams
despite his step back from WoW and focus
on a more diverse streaming style
he'd never lost touch with his roots and
this org was an opportunity for him to
involve himself in WoW eSports scene
northern gaming would go on to be
acquired by NRG and soda joined on with
the northern game he basically just got
bought up by NRG and as a result I
became a part owner of NRG I don't own
that much it is a very small amount but
technically I am an owner so we've got
this story of a guy who has been here
since the beginning a WoW star who's
been streaming since he was 14 made it
big and stopped playing Wow but that
didn't matter
because his viewers stuck with him as he
played a bunch of other games gambled
and documented his life online but while
it may all seem like an online
Cinderella story soda Poppins narrative
is not won without controversy as twitch
has grown so has its audience and over
the course of the last five years many
have seen a platform as a career path a
place where if you have something of
value to offer you can end up living the
dream but as people have flocked to
twitch for their chance to cash out
those who've been there from the
beginning have stood up to maintain the
status quo and that's not always a good
look
Harry don't dude later Judy I got kicked
for being abusive I called up Judy and
he kicked me bro in 2015
sodapoppin expressed his controversial
opinion on women streamers who were
entering the space and was particularly
critical of those spending more time in
full cam than playing games now where a
real girl game yeah that's how much
gameplay I want on my stream while soda
and his fanbase considered this a
harmless critique others saw it as yet
another major personality pushing women
out of the space something that has been
a problem in the community since day one
to me when I watched it sodapoppin he
came off as like a super pompous
self-important douchebag this take is in
line with an ongoing theme within his
channel soda has become increasingly
jaded about a community that's changing
and is extremely open about his distaste
for much of the modern twitch ecosystem
you got people trying to white knight
and hopes that maybe they'll get laid by
their favorite streamer when in reality
they're already married again twitch is
a giant glorified mental hospital and
some of that darkside looked to people
like soda the oft banned xqc and other
our livestream fails characters like
Greek god X for their take on all of the
latest twitch drama sometimes these
conversations are like walking through a
minefield should I built this you have
one [ __ ] last chance should I build
yeah I don't cast don't be an [ __ ] on
stream it's not me cannot believe you
idiots keep talking like a tips soda has
also been no stranger to short
suspensions
his often crude style of humor has
landed him with suspensions for
violating twitches Terms of Service
throughout the entirety of his modern
streaming
I got banned cuz I streamed on a second
account and I watch streamers I think I
got reported maybe I'm not sure I
actually don't know the full details
that said these crackdowns from twitch
have done nothing but grow his
popularity and are something he's woven
into his identity as a streamer half you
guys kind of just hate me and that's why
you watched me I don't want you guys
being there and [ __ ] sometimes I just
want to stream he's become in recent
years somewhat of a bad boy one of the
last remaining symbols of an era where
twitch was more or less the Wild West of
the Internet you shouldn't be able to do
this on Twitch it's not talking about
like that but in many ways soda has
worked to temper the sometimes
controversial nature of his channel I
don't want to go I don't want to have
anything on my car that's going to put
me in a very awkward conversation right
now
awkward being I don't want to make
people upset I wouldn't want to put
something there are only two genders on
my car because I think there's only two
genders I agree with that however I
don't want to have some ass shade like
some angry woman just yell at me it's a
lot of pressure to be that guy who's
been there since the beginning he's a
streamer gamer social worker friend
performer and gesture all at one time oh
oh my god oh my god immediate pain but
recently he's made some brief attempts
to make his viewers aware of the nasty
placed which can sometimes be like like
Esmond gold for example he didn't ban
anything in his stream and he talked
about this he didn't ban anything in his
stream and some people were like memeing
to be like racist or whatever they were
doing that I'll be the first to say
sometimes it can actually be kind of
funny it can be like this the subtle
stuff but he came down to a point he
came to realize they were genuine
in his channel as of February 2018
he's never dipped below 20,000 average
viewers in a month what the hell is this
huh it's a dead pig he's become the
go-to variety streamer on Twitch and is
one of the only major streamers able to
juggle games while maintaining his
viewership oh [ __ ] he's also never let
go of the game that made him famous in
the first place during august of 2018 he
saw a massive spike in viewership during
the latest Wow expansion and recently
during the re-release of classic Wow he
received a similar spike oh god it's as
shitty as I want it to be - even as a
variety streamer day to day he's never
lost touch with his base and in my
channel I have so many advantages it's
disgusting I can go under a new game
that no one else is playing and that
game will be pushed up to like the top
10 games on Twitch the reality of
streaming in the modern world is that
many broadcasters are linked to their
game of choice names like ninja and dr.
Lupo go hand in hand with fortnight
shroud is the king of the FPS genre and
pro players like double lifts are
obviously an extension of the game they
dominate I like all streamers the only
streamers that I really don't like are
ones that try way too hard to cater to
like the vocal negative people I hate
that stuff I got [ __ ] hate it and
whenever I see it happening I'm like
dude that's really just gross
but sodapoppin isn't just a gamer
anymore he's transcended back
he can play hand simulator for hours and
well that's just par for the course on
his channel
I can't pick something off of the ground
ah okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I just got my [ __ ]
axe he may approach it in a nonchalant
way but so does weekly cadence has
become sort of like a week of camp
there's events planned every day you
know what to expect but things can get
out of hand at any time from the full
playthroughs he does during the week
that allow his viewers to vicariously
travel through the new biggest titles
and gaming with him start a new game
probably gonna do survival excuse me sir
I need that thank you I'll take another
one of these it's always good to have
extra water that's the only way of
getting water this early on really - his
hilarious back and forth with his
friends and fellow streamers Greek god x
and xqc
to whatever the hell is going on here
please tell them me that she may refer
to you soon on state to male time where
his viewers sent him whatever they want
and he opens it all on stream the hell
Sara note no note someone just sent me
chocolate a bag of dog food retro pop up
hot dog toaster is actually a hot dog
toaster yes we did it
high stood what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
with this thing to his sometimes
intoxicated and always entertaining live
streams this is me outside with
sunglasses I can't it's hard to see [ __ ]
to the origins of his variety streaming
[ __ ] show Saturday where he runs through
a massive list of games in one day all
decided by his chat I'm sorry there's
some we've game show Saturday now that's
just what [ __ ] releases bro look at
this quality
the graphics are next-generation and of
course sellout Sunday where he hangs out
and watches YouTube and listens to music
all of which are decided by chat
donations sellout Sunday let's start
again
[Music]
he even returned to his competitive Wow
roots and competed in a classic Wow pvp
invitational tournament where he showed
that he still got it in chance moves
round to deal with the damage it's
coming out right now either and this
will be round two for chance you will
move on to the next round
good good game and to you maybe more so
than any other streamer this cadence is
sodas life he's been extremely honest
about just how much of his life is
consumed by his channel I did a 37 hour
stream and the next day I was like no
I'm not streaming today but maybe I'll
feel good enough to stream the next day
woke up the next day I was like now how
am i shooting today either
and then I tweeted out I'm like I need
time off like I just had this mentally
ill awakening moment I need time off
speed in his own words he truly doesn't
have much more than what we see on
camera and that's kind of the way he
likes it the only thing I've achieved is
streaming min I haven't done anything
else I'm pretty happy with where my life
went I'm very satisfied with it of
course there are things you complain
about being a streamer but man do we
have it good I mean truly have it
[ __ ] great so that's one thing I got
to double down on a make sure y'all know
that I realize with his chat right next
to him he's reflecting he's laughing
he's traversing all of life's most
difficult questions live and right in
front of you people just belittle
streaming and say it's literally just
playing video against like okay it's
really not hard to tell that it's a at
least a little bit more than that and
what you see is what you get
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]